hello there you're watching the press
preview a first look at what's on the
front pages
as they arrive tonight in the next half
hour we'll see what's making the
headlines with the broadcaster and
former mp anna subari there they are and
the political journalist
isabel oakshot so let's see what's on
some of those front pages
the guardian leads with scientists
encouraging the government to delay the
last
loosening of lockdown on june 21st and
allow
second doses of the covert vaccine to be
given sooner
the metro greets that news with the
headline third wave alert
the telegraph carries a joint letter
from four global health and financial
bodies urging g7 governments to step up
their commitment
to providing vaccines to third world
countries
the mail leads with its own campaign
calling on the government to scrap
holiday covered tests saying they're a
ripoff
the eye has seen data revealing that out
of more than 7
800 complaints of racist behavior by
police officers in the period concerned
only 181 led to further action
face of hope now in almost 2 million
nh how excuse me in almost 2 million nhs
2 million pounds should we try that
again 2 million pound nhs treatment
has helped save this baby arthur morgan
and could do the same for many others
that's on the
daily mail mira and the financial times
has a word of a restructuring at the
accountancy firm ey
as it grapples with the potential
fallout from its involvement
with the collapse of the payments
company wirecard
and as i was saying we're joined tonight
by anna subri and isabel oakshot
good evening to you both i hope you
enjoyed your bank holiday
um let's kick off with the metro third
wave
alert we're on a knife edge scientist
say anna
well i'm not when i say i'm not sure
about that i mean i
you know the whole of this has is meant
to be led
by the data and if you look at the data
of course the vaccine program has been a
huge success
the vaccine has been a huge success and
we are now
up to almost 50 percent of our
population that's had two
jabs and i'm not doubting that there is
um
a rise because of the so-called indian
variant
but you know if we're not reopening on
june the 21st
my real thoughts are with businesses and
that will have a
it's really difficult for these guys
they need
certainty they need to know whether or
not they need to
order the extra things that they will
need if they're in restaurants and pubs
and bars
cafes and so on then there's all the the
other
arm of hospitality and it's the lack of
certainty which will damage i think a
lot of our businesses and goodness knows
they've
experienced enough damage and if i may
say finally i think it would be helpful
if a lot of these scientists
actually were quiet if we're doing this
let's do it properly through sage let's
have a proper analysis of the data
but i would caution this government
about
yes rushing into um ending all of it
before the date is right but equally
don't underestimate the damage it will
do to british businesses
well they'll probably argue that they
are looking at the data and as you look
at the government data from today
it's all rising isn't it um isabel what
do you think because we've been
learnt yeah it's small percentages it it
is
um but it's about time and time again
we've learnt with this virus that if you
don't act fast it just
gets completely out of control well i
don't think we're anywhere near that and
i would go further than anna and i think
this kind of language from
individuals on stage talking about
britain being on a knife edge is
incredibly unhelpful
let's actually look at the figures
they're vanishingly small at the moment
there are 743
people in hospital with covid the
majority of those people probably have
other health conditions to put that in
context are 140
000 hospital beds in the uk so
43 is nothing and there's one death in
the last day
1600 people a day die of many
different causes about 300 of them from
cancer so these figures are
absolutely tiny and as
anna rightly says the vaccine program
has been a really big success the vast
majority of people who need the vaccine
have now had one or both jabs so it
seems to me that there's absolutely no
basis whatsoever
for now talking and in this alarmist
fashion about having to delay
the ending of all restrictions well
let's just look at the figures people
tested positive
these are um government figures from
today
in the last 24 hour period 28.8
a rise of that in people testing
positive debts you did say
one daily death that hasn't happened
since last july but it is
up in the last seven days up 45
um patients of digital hospital 23.2
and um virus tests conducted 1.3
obviously it's key
how much testing we're doing um anna do
you think also key is the fact that
the vaccination drive has been so
successful
so we may be looking at this remembering
december
but we didn't have the vaccination rate
then absolutely and you see that
the other thing is about all of this is
that the government told us and rightly
i think
the only way out of it was the vaccine
and so looking at this from the
perspective of just all the reviewers
they will be saying well hang on a
moment we were all told
if we get jabbed up um and this vaccine
is rolled out in the the astonishing way
that it has
and with the great take up as well then
we could begin to return to normality
and so you know all throughout this
pandemic we've had a big problem with
the government
over over promising and then under
delivering
and so i think there are all sorts of
risks but i
i i do say they want to make it very
clear that data
is important but if you as you rightly
identify
put it into perspective we are nowhere
like we were
in march last year and indeed in
december and in the september of last
year
so yeah be cautious but goodness me
you know we we we do need to be
realistic
about the alternatives if we don't get
back to some sort of normality on june
21st the scientists will probably say
that we do have to be realistic
and they are right to raise these
concerns and they are looking at the
data do you think isabelle that
yes they can say this they should be
saying this
but really we should be looking two
weeks down the line
when we make that call
well the government's not going to make
a decision a final decision for another
two weeks anyway but i want to pick up
the percentages that you read out which
sounded so alarming because i really
think they
once again they do need context i looked
at my own area
what the statistics are for uh west
oxfordshire where i live
and alarmingly uh the number of hospital
admissions for coronavirus has gone up
300
but guess what that's from naught to
four four people
so these statistics you've got to look
them
at them in context and i think this is a
real moment now a real test of boris
johnson's leadership
and what he does now will set the tone
for the next six months to the
next year even for the next two years in
our country are we going to
rediscover some some backbone in the
face of
of these minor minor wobbles uh and
what do you make sorry to jump in there
what do you make of bolton
though area sorry carry on what do you
make of places like bolton do you think
that moving forward
where they don't have figures like you
have in your area
they do have a rising number of the
india variant do you think what we need
to do is have local lockdowns
no i don't think we need any lockdowns
at all local lockdowns are just
not helpful at this point i think we've
got to get away from obsessing
about so-called cases and then being
positive
results of tests about a third of people
are asymptomatic most of the people
who are testing positive are now young
people they're not actually ill
so it doesn't in a sense matter that
much they do you spread it
yes but if everybody's been vaccinated
in the vulnerable groups
that doesn't actually they're not about
who are they and i go ahead
no it doesn't no it's no no it's not
quite as simple as that we know that
the vaccine although it's brilliant
though it's still it only gives
eighty percent of protection to only
eight percent people and so
there will always be some people even if
they've had two jabs
who will still get the very worst
effects of the disease the point about
where i do this where i absolutely do
agree with isabel about local lockdowns
there's no point locking down
in bolton because people will literally
be able to travel a few miles and
they'll be able to go to the pub
and be able to enjoy it be like
non-lockdown
what you need absolutely is testing
and then you need a very these surge
vaccinations as well and that is
occurring in a lot of these areas where
local authorities know better
frankly than anybody and they can get
into those communities
and they can make sure that people are
getting vaccinated that is the way out
of it all
it's by everybody getting vaccinated but
the real question is how many people are
going
into hospital because one we don't want
people to get serious disease
secondly of course we don't want our nhs
wherever it might be a country
to be overcome and overwhelmed
by a flood of people with very serious
disease from coving
that's not what we're seeing um just
before we go to break let's look at the
daily telegraph
give the third world extra jabs to halt
variants
one wonders how many times this plea can
be made before it's actually actioned
isabel what do you think
well i think this is a really
interesting and important story it's a
letter jointly written by the
heads of the world health organization
the imf and the wto
appealing to countries such as our own
where we do have
the wherewithal to actually be generous
and share
some of our vaccine capability
to do so because in the end coronavirus
and this pandemic
is a global problem and unless all parts
of the world benefit from the amazing
vaccine programs that we've had or at
least some bit of it
then we're all going to be disadvantaged
so rather than
talk about vaccinating young children
which i think is a
deeply disturbing debate that is now
underway
if we've got that spare capability let's
give it elsewhere
anna what do you think you know just
what was it last week we were reporting
from south sudan
on how there they've got kovacs jabs
no one's taking them up and now they've
shipped them off
across the border to kenya to see if
they're going to use them but should we
be giving them the jabs if they're not
going to use them
of course no of course we should and we
we need a concerted effort actually i
i have a friend and a neighbor who said
to me you know i got my vaccine
effectively for nothing
and wanted to make a donation of the
cost of the vaccine if somebody
calculate how much that dose would have
been to some of the great charities that
will be involved
in kovacs not just our government but
also there'll be charities like red
cross and oxfam and so on and so forth
already delivering great work in these
countries
who one could make a donation to so that
they could speed up
uh this this the vaccination being
rolled out across the
across the world because you know yet
again isabel this is very worried
i accept or upset a number of of your
editors that we are agreeing so much
this evening but isn't that good
because it is right that unless
everybody is in receipt of this
vaccination no one is safe we're not all
safe
until everyone is safe and and we need
now some really big serious thinking
about how we persuade
countries like sudan wherever it may be
in the world
that they need to take this vaccination
and that can be done and again it's at a
local level
and it's often but through general
persuasion of people making people
understand
how it doesn't just protect them but
actually protects their communities
okay annabelle isabel anna thank you so
much
um we're going to take a quick break
there but coming up
nice work if you can get it we'll tell
you about the charity bosses earning
hitting the prime minister when we come
back
welcome back you're watching the press
preview with me now anna subre
and isabel oak shot um hello again
thanks a lot i'll call you your proper
names now not sort of like
brenifer or something okay let's go back
to the daily telegraph um
this may not actually come as a shock to
many people but
what did you think charity chiefs earn
more than the prime minister
so the prime minister earns 157
000 pounds a year so you might
make the argument that it wouldn't
actually be that difficult for somebody
in a very senior position which a lot of
these
bosses are because they're running huge
sometimes huge organizations you know
you're not talking about a few hundred
thousand pounds that's a lot of money
but you're talking actually about
hundreds of millions of pounds
and so you need your top dollar unique
properly good
people running a lot of these charities
however
the point that's being made i think
quite rightly by helen stevenson he's
the chief
executive of the charities commission is
that especially given the
big problems that a lot of charities are
going to be um
following the covid pandemic is they've
got to look very carefully at
how much money they do pay and making
sure that they are
using donors money ordinary people's
money
they're using it wisely and properly and
i think that
whilst you do need you know you need the
best
running charities for obvious reasons
huge sums of money as i say in many
instances nevertheless
they are charities and you certainly
don't want that feeling
that donors money's not being spent
wisely so she makes a good point yeah
isabel what do you think i mean the
welcome trust
the highest paid employee their chief
investment officer taking home
4.64 million pounds that includes salary
and bonuses last year that's
a 1.3 million pound rise on the year
before
what's the argument for this i mean i
thought
i thought this was a really interesting
story actually i mean
anna is right the prime minister really
has quite a modest
salary for somebody with this huge
weight of responsibility i mean i would
make the argument that the prime
minister should be paid
at least half a million pounds i mean we
can't feel too sorry for them because
as david cameron and many of his
predecessors have shown once they leave
they certainly coin it in you know they
will make millions
but nonetheless it's a very uh really
pretty modest salary for the amount of
weight on their shoulders
i think people would be pretty
astonished at the idea
that the boss of the welcome trust it's
not it's a chief investment officer i
think
earns a little shy of five million
there's something
uh that makes me feel pretty queasy
about that and
and really anything uh over two hundred
thousand and it's hard to put a cut off
point but there's something i think most
people will find a little uncomfortable
about that
of course you need really well qualified
people to run
huge organizations but something's gone
pretty wrong
when people are earning these enormous
sums
in a charity when you've got others are
donors
you know really doing their best to give
a few
pounds or a few uh 100 pounds here or
there and hoping that it's going to the
right thing not just a
month in some cases especially
given the fact and what do you think
we've had the foreign aid cut
did you see that package that we've been
running on south sudan
where you know kids aren't going to
school they're sharing textbooks
disgraceful and you've got someone here
to welcome trust obviously nothing
to do with that south sudan package but
4.64 million pounds that is
eye-watering i i look
there's an outbreak again of agreement
on this um i'm i'm struggling to justify
it
as well i mean we agree that we do need
people who are eminently well qualified
and able to do this and that often means
you have to tempt people out of the
private sector
then i think you could start to ask some
other serious questions about
some of the remuneration of our top
executives in british business
and but the point about the cuts in
foreign aid
i mean i'm certainly of the view that
this is one of the most disgraceful
things that this government has done
it's broken the manifesto pledge
it's broken the pledge to the the
poorest people in the world
and it is shameful on our country that
we have a government that's cut off
foreign aid
at a time when actually we need to be
making sure that we do exactly the right
thing
by those countries across the world who
are nothing like as prosperous and that
and that absolutely
chimes in but we're gonna we're gonna
have to leave it there yeah we're gonna
have to leave it there i mean
they're looking for value for taxpayers
money in those countries but we're going
to have to leave it
there yeah um thank you so much we'll be
back in the next hour we'll see you then
i'm joined tonight by anna suberi and
isabel oakshot
right june the 21st let's get on with it
because this is what everyone is talking
about
um isabel you
don't think the scientists are right do
you
oh hang on a minute i'm not going to
argue with the scientists
uh interpretation let's not delay okay
go ahead
yeah yeah so of course the only story
really uh at the moment
is uh about all about the june 21st date
are we or are we not going to see an
end of these uh desperately difficult
restrictions that everybody has put up
with for a very very long time
and there's a lot of very alarmist
language around from a select
few scientists including figures on
sages
papers quote one uh sage member talking
about the uk being on a knife edge
and a significant really looks what
looks to me like a lobbying campaign now
to delay the easing of the lockdown the
final lockdown restrictions
i think it's really important when we
look at some of the
scary sounding statistics about huge
percentage rises
in the number of cases of coronavirus
just to put them in context there are at
the moment
only 743 people in hospital
uh with coronavirus and just to put that
in some kind of context there are about
140
000 hospital beds so these figures are
tiny only one person
died of coronavirus in the last 24 hours
so when you read about a spike in the
number of cases yes cases are rising but
from a very very
low base and it doesn't seem to me any
justification now
for prolonging uh the any kind of
lockdown measures
well i'll put to you i'll put you what
adam finn from the jcvi
told us he said if we wake up in the
middle of july and realize we were too
cautious and we could have relaxed
things sooner
well i think that's a mistake that we
can all live with because we can then
move forward and say well done us
at least we took care and we're careful
the mistake is going to be
to rush forward and then fall flat on
our faces by rushing
forwards too fast
isabel well i'm not sure who she
pretends to be
to be speaking for i mean if we can look
back and and
we were too close to the jcvi
that might be all right for some
categories of people but for all the
people who are desperately waiting for
operations for example people who are
now entering two-year waiting lists for
a hip-hop for example because the nhs is
virtually shut down except to deal with
everything
only to deal with coronavirus for the
last year all those people whose
livelihoods are on the line
who if they have more uncertainty are
simply not going to be able to make
their businesses
viable so some of these scientists act
as if there is
absolutely no consequence to delaying
the easing of lockdown as if
this is the only thing that matters and
actually the collateral damage
continues to be absolutely enormous so
it's time to get some
perspective back i i think they do
realize i mean ravi gupta
anna what do you think ravi gupta from
nerve tag i said i think the problem is
we're not too
far from reaching the sort of levels of
vaccination that would help us contain
the virus and i think that people are
not saying we should
abandon the june 21st date altogether
but just to delay it
by a few weeks while we gather more
intelligence and we can look at the
trajectory in a clearer way
if we look at the costs and benefits of
getting it wrong
i think it is heavily in favor of delay
well look we know that we've made
mistakes in the past
we know that we were too late going into
the march lockdown last year and we know
that we've
got it horribly wrong in the autumn and
then again going into christmas and when
you say horribly wrong
we mean that tens of thousands of people
died who didn't need to die
we're in a very different position now
because of the huge success of the
vaccine
and the fact that it has a it's it's
very good
and it is you know it is up to 80 90
percent efficient
in stopping serious disease and also of
course so many tens of millions of
people haven't just had one but now
two doses of it so all around success
there and the po
and i agree with isabel the point is the
is the
is the actual figures themselves and
we've got to be
this has got to be based on the data
with a good dose of common sense
and when you take all of that into the
round i
i'm not happy frankly about scientists
going into the media dare i say
and sort of get i know it's a good story
and everything just don't think it's
terribly helpful because at the end of
the day this government has to make
these decisions
um but you know i just feel for all
those businesses who are saying well
you know dear god you know we just need
certainty we need
to know i mean you had it in your report
you know going up to 100
capacity is is make or break stuff for
them
uh and the uncertainty is very bad for
business it's not good for us the rest
of us either
because people are desperate you know if
the vaccine is the silver bullet
then why are we talking now about not
ending all the restrictions arguably
until july maybe the end of july
even later that if you've got it
with you yeah right now fully
vaccinated and even if they do get that
second job there's there's a lag but
listen let's leave that because i
think we could actually debate it until
june the 21st
um let's look at the daily mail they've
got this campaign
um pcr tests they really are
extortionate aren't they isabel
if you're looking at going on holiday
the pcr tests alone could cost more than
your tickets
well i think this is a really important
campaign by the daily mail and i speak
from experience here because a couple of
months ago
i came back from a long period abroad
with my
three children and i had to spend in the
region of a thousand
pounds on mandatory coronavirus testing
of course none of us had coronavirus but
nonetheless we had to go through this
rigmarole test before you get on the
plane test when you get back
you have to have two and then you have
to have another one if you want to get
out of quarantine early
and the point that the daily mail makes
is that the cost of these mandatory
tests
is extortionate relative to what people
are being charged
in other countries so often times you
find that you're having to pay
around 140 150 pounds
for example for a fit to fly coronavirus
test whereas overseas and i know this
because i've done it
you can get these tests for 40 quid so
why is it
that the government is allowing this
tremendous rip-off not only that but
they're actually sort of participating
in it
by mandating certain companies
that you have to use in order to have
the test it's available
much more cheaply and i applaud the
daily mail for
trying to get some common sense into
this well the argument i suppose is that
the equipment is just so expensive but
the daily mail does say that they
they're urging the treasury to act vat
on these tests i'm sure that will cut
quite a
large amount of uh the cost out and what
do you think
yeah and i think you see the other thing
is the pcr test is much more expensive
than the lateral flow test
and so if you have a pcr test it's 99
pounds
um well that is a
common pricing if i may say boots the
others are obviously available is 99
pounds
but a lateral flow test is less and
there's a lot of confusion because
you need a pcr test to get out but you
can come back in from
green zone areas on a lateral flow test
as isabel says
you then have to take even from a green
zone another test and i think if we
they really put this into context there
are real families who've not had a
holiday for a long time
and many of those families either one or
both of them have been
absolutely on the front line and there
is nothing wrong
with them wanting to have two weeks or a
week in the sunshine and it's an
extraordinary amount of money
for a classic and typical family of four
and it's almost like the government is
saying you know you're not really
allowed out and if you have to go
somewhere sunny how dare you we're going
to make you pay through the
teeth for it and i i just feel the whole
thing is
is not good and i think the male might
have hit on this
i'm not sure how much cheaper it is in
other countries
but i think it really matters maybe when
people are being ripped off everywhere
no well i was actually talking to
someone um in east africa who's saying
it was about
20 pounds for a pcr test though i'm not
entirely sure how that's
um feasible yeah i was quite surprised
as well a pcr test
so the cost should be going down yeah
exactly isabel
sorry go ahead well i know it's cheaper
elsewhere because i've been to quite a
few countries where it is cheaper as i
say it was 40 pounds in the
in the gulf um
it is yes very much easier to get and in
some countries it's indeed free
so look this really comes down to the
attitude of
the government of the country consent
and i and i agree with anna i don't
think the government
wants us to go abroad they're making it
as difficult as it
possibly can be i think they probably
disagree with that
saying they're keeping the high the
costs high to keep us here um listen
let's take a break
um anna isabel we'll be back in a moment
thanks uh coming up tennis player naomi
osaka withdrawals from the french open
will ask whether the media expects too
much from these sports tasks
join us after the break
hello again you're watching the press
preview with me now anna subrie and
isabelle oakshot
hello to you both um listen in this half
let's not do any covert
we do need a break sometimes let's talk
about naomi osaka
she's on the times and everywhere really
um
anna what do you think do you think she
has a right not
to do those press conferences after the
matches
well i don't think she has a legal right
in the sense that it's in her contract
that she's
meant to take part i don't think they
should be doing this stuff if they don't
want to shouldn't be in their contract
she's 23. she's a she's a sports person
she she's not an entertainer i mean she
wanted to be an entertainer she had gone
to radha
she and you know i think they're looking
at this the wrong way
um because there have been instances and
it seems to be a problem in tennis no
other sport seems to have
a a press conference where people can
frankly just be rude
and i would much rather the tennis
authorities if they say that people have
to come
almost immediately off the court and
then do this huge press conference
anybody who can't be civil and actually
offends somebody who's
if they're struggling with some ghastly
defeat
and then they're basically asked why are
you so rubbish i'm not surprised they
don't want to do it i don't think they
should have to do i think the tennis
authorities
should boot people out if they can't be
polite i'm fed up with this rudeness
that seems to be perfectly acceptable i
don't think it's doing any of us any
favors on
society at all and even if they aren't
rude it's not just this one
even if they aren't rude it's such a
difficult thing to do isn't it to be
under that immense
pressure of a match lose the match and
then you don't have any sort of down
time no debriefing with your coach
straight into a press conference with
the world's media
and having to take that on board what
did you think isabel of the french opens
reaction finding her what ten thousand
pounds
and then saying well we're going to
disqualify you if you don't do it
well i think this has been
extraordinarily badly handled and i
think there'll be a lot of
soul-searching
uh following the uh statement very very
heartfelt statement that the tennis star
has put out i read the statement and
i just thought it was so very genuine
and
many people will have just empathized
with her
her difficulties you know it is
incredibly intimidating
to face the world's press after uh
competitions like these
and it seems to be that the the tennis
authorities in this case have really
misread the zeitgeist
and the way that people are now really
trying to have much more
understanding and empathy for mental
health
issues like this tennis player has very
openly admits she suffers from
serious anxiety and depression
and i think there'll be quite a backlash
over the way
the organizers of the competition have
handled it
it's going to be interesting to see how
other tournaments deal with it and what
sort of support she gets from
other players isn't isn't it um okay ft
now
finally what do you make of this anna
the chinese
changing their child policy
i mean this was a particularly cruel and
unpleasant
policy that china's had for a number of
years and it started off where
you couldn't have more than one child
and there were some
terrible stories out coming out of china
where
of the consequences of that forced
abortions and
and just heartbreak for people who were
you know
forced by law to not to have more than
one child and then they changed that to
two now it's to three
and they've done it not through any sort
of acts of great act of humanity which
would have been the right way but for
harsh economics because they now have an
aging population
and they find because they're finding
themselves increasingly the families
actually
almost some of them by choice are not
having more than one or two children
so they almost now are positively
encouraging people now that's happened
in other countries
where there's been a problem with an
asian population and younger people
not having the number of children that
they had in the past effectively to
support that
um all the population very different in
china
um it was it's all been done for
economic reasons and it just
i think shows what a at its heart is a
brutal and
inhumane regime but it also highlights
the fact doesn't it that even when they
scrap the one child policy isabel
it's so expensive to have children that
people just weren't
briefly we're running out of time now
yeah it's extraordinary really that
china is still mandating how many
children people can have but as anna
says this tells you all you need to know
about the nature of that regime which is
deeply sinister in so many ways so yeah
great that they've relaxed their policy
but why are they bossing about their
population and interfering in how many
children they have in the first place
okay
anna isabel it's been great thank you so
much for being with us this evening
thank you pleasure